hi it's michelle from lamb muffin beauty
size chemistry phd skin care nerd
and owner of freshly bleached hair i've
had a lot of questions about how i
maintain my hair
and i did a video about my hair routine
back in january but
a few things have changed since then
mostly i've gotten even more lazy
so i thought i'd film an update if you
like finding out more about the science
behind beauty products click the like
the subscribe and click the notification
bell so you don't miss any videos
so i went to the same salon as last time
which is ultra fade by rich
and this time i had a different
hairdresser and i think she went a
little bit less hard on my hair
so it's a little bit less white than
last time
but it's still light enough that i can
get this color i think the biggest
difference from last time is that i
started using amy dimethico dimethicone
products
from the first wash my hair's a lot more
manageable than last time
it's a lot less damaged i don't think
i've seen a single split end even though
last time there were tons
i do think aimo dimethicone was the
biggest game changer for me even more
than olaplex
it's a silicone that doesn't weigh down
your hair quite as much as most of the
common silicones
or at least with my hair i've had a lot
of people tell me that it worked really
well for them too
emma dimethicone has a positive charge
like charges repel
and so you can't get too much ammo
dimethicone in your hair
once it's in there another
hemodimethrical molecule can't get that
close to it and so you don't end up with
too much buildup
mhi methicone also crosslinks and forms
a film and so that can last through
several washes
that means that the smooth feeling that
you get after you wash your hair and
conditioner
that will last for a bit longer and so
having this smooth feel means that when
you brush it when you
tie it up when you do whatever with your
hair it's a lot smoother it doesn't snag
on things and it doesn't snag on
itself and so that prevents future
damage so the exact products i've been
using with amer dimethicone have changed
i've been using the tony and guide
volume addiction conditioner
i was using this last time as well the
problem with this
is that there are a bunch of different
versions and not all of them have amor
dimethicone really high up on the
ingredients list so
usually i look at that as an indication
that there's a bit more in it
i get this from the supermarket and it
goes on half price all the time so every
time i go grocery shopping i
wander through the shampoo aisle and
check and stock up if it's
at eight dollars i've also been trying
this garnier treatment
it is the sleek and shine leave-in
conditioning cream
i got this from iherb i don't know if
it's actually available in australia
it's a leave-in treatment so if my
hair's been feeling a bit rough
after i wash it i'll add a bit of this
on the ends sometimes i'll mix it with
oliplex 3 or 6 to
get that extra bond repair as well so
because ammo dimethicone has been
working so well for me i've been able to
wash my hair more frequently so i wash
it every second day which is my
preferred amount
i have a pretty oily scalp so i've been
using a lot less dry shampoo
i haven't had a lot of success with dry
shampoo because a lot of them tend to
irritate my scalp
so it's really nice that i get to avoid
that now but it does mean that i do have
to re-dye my hair a bit more often
by re-dyeing what i mean is i use
shampoos and conditioners that deposit
color
and my hair isn't like a really bright
color so it doesn't need that much dye
so my favorite that i was using last
time as well is the flash professional
clean blonde violet turning shampoo
with a lot of the other purple shampoos
i've been trying i found that they tend
to dry out my hair and dry out my scalp
my hair can't handle any more drying so
this is
really good i've also been using a new
brand called kin k yn
unfortunately they are a clean brand and
i think you all know my feelings about
clean brands
but they do have a rose gold shampoo and
i haven't really found
other brands that do pink shampoos let
me know if you know of any
i am trying to go for like a pinkish
purple color
right now it's probably a bit too purple
and silvery gray which is great but
not quite the color i'm aiming for yeah
so i've been
alternating between pink and purple
colors to try to keep it within
the color i want if it's a bit too
purple i use the pink if it's a bit too
pink i use the purple
the main reason why i've been going for
pinkish this time even though i love
this silvery purple color
is that in this blended region um
between where it's black
and where it's bleached it tends to go a
bit brassy
and it's a lot easier to hide that
brassiness if you have a warm hair color
so a lot of the time when my hair is
this
cool purple it'll start off the first
day after i wash it looking really good
and then after a while it
just starts looking a bit like brown and
because the brown doesn't really work
with cool it mostly just looks dirty
so this time really i'm going for that
purplish pink color and i'm not really
trying to get it all the one color
so last time i tried to always just have
my hair all one color but this time i'm
kind of okay with it being
slightly different colors everywhere i
think it's partly just because i'm
indecisive about whether i want pink or
purple
the ends of my hair are a little bit
stained from my old die
and so it's a bit brassier it's a bit
hard to see on this camera i think
but it's a bit brassier than the rest of
my hair so i think this sort of mixed
color is working quite well for me and
it's also a lot lower maintenance
so again i do all of my hair coloring in
the shower
nothing stays on my hair for more than
like three minutes because i'm pretty
impatient
last time i used to always dye my hair
once every two or three weeks
and that's just too much effort for me
now so everything is just
colored shampoos and conditioners with
colored conditioner i mix it myself
i put my dye in a lush tub and blend it
out with uberless hydrating conditioner
i got this ages ago and i don't know why
i don't really use it on my hair as
conditioner i just always end up mixing
it
probably because it doesn't have much
ammo dimethicone the die i've been using
is the brand especially plus this is
really good because it's like a three
minute
hair dye unfortunately i can't find this
on ebay
anymore or anywhere really so if you
have another good suggestion for
a three minute hair dye i am really
really keen on that
in the shower i always use a crocodile
clip these just hold
a massive amount of hair this one is
from a brand called cricket i picked it
up
at a hair convention in the before times
it has
these ribbed or dotty grips
which means that it's really easy to
hold on to in the shower
so this can hold like all of my hair
and i have quite a lot of hair
yeah so it holds it all it holds a lot
of it even like when it's doubled up
on top of my hair um yeah so it has this
cool mechanism
where you can hold large amounts
and it'll still grip really hard another
amazing product that i've recently found
is the igk mixed feelings leave-in
blonde toning drops
this is a really intense purple product
that has the same purple dye
as purple shampoos you can mix this into
anything i mix it a lot into
my garnier leave-in conditioning mix i
mix it into my die
if you do get this just to let you know
you press the bottom
of the tube to get the drops out you
don't just like shake it like this and
hope that something comes out
so don't do what i did for 15 minutes
sometimes if i do see a bit of
brassiness here i'll just
put a couple of drops on my hands rub
them together to spread it and then just
do this very quickly and then wash my
hands immediately to stop it from
staining
and that works really well as well for
drying my hair i'm still using the
aqueous towels that i got
years ago these are microfiber towels
that are designed to dry your hair
really really quickly so when your hair
is wet it's at its most fragile and so
you just want to blot it dry as
much as you can i really like how light
these are so if you wrap it up in a
turban on your head
it doesn't hurt your neck it doesn't
fall all over the place
with hair dryers i'm still using the
panasonic one
this has that nano e stuff in the top
and so i found that it dries my hair out
a lot less than the dyson which i was
also using before
this has a really good mode which is the
scalp mode this gets it to like the
perfect temperature
to blast the top of your hair without
burning your scalp
i have found that in this new working
from home life i've been washing my hair
earlier in the day
so that way i don't have to dry my hair
as much at night so
if my hair's still damp like an hour
before i go to bed i just give it a
quick whiz
for brushing my hair i'm still using the
tangle teezers i find these really good
for
getting through your hair without too
much tugging
so even if you put it up the top and
then if you get to a stuck bit like
don't tear it through just like
gently apply pressure and it will
detangle itself so you don't have to
like
do that whole thing i've been using silk
pillow cases almost exclusively now i
found that silk is just really nice on
my hair
especially because it's so easily
damaged now i've been using these ones
from lilly silk
they're good they're cheap but they are
a bit thin so they might not last as
long as something that's thicker
i have one from silk which has lasted
ages
also this is a tool i got off ebay
it's meant to be like a shower scalp
scrubber
i haven't really worked out how to use
it i can't really tell if i like it or
not
i think you just shampoo your hair and
just put it on there and try to do that
but i do feel like it is tugging a bit
on my hair which i'm not sure is the
best for it while it's wet
so if you've ever used one of these and
you can give me some tips or tell me
what your experiences were
let me know in the comments with hair
ties i usually do wear my hair in a
ponytail
i've been using these thick hair ties
that i got off ebay i'm pretty sure they
were
like ten dollars for a hundred or
something
but these are really good because they
don't have an end
so there's no rough snaggy bit that gets
caught on your hair the cats have been
stealing these so
every couple of years i just have to buy
200 and that usually lasts me
i think i straight up forgot to talk
about this last time but i also have
this shaver
so i have an undercut because my hair i
just got too much hair
so i'll see if i can show
you oh
there it is so yeah i just have too much
hair
so i found that cutting that has made my
hair a lot thinner
a lot lighter and it dries a lot more
quickly so you can probably see how
messy the undercut is
and that's because i'd shave it myself
every once in a while i try to get
someone to help me shave it but
usually it's just me in the shower i
bend over and i use this
this is a remington shaver and i pretty
much just grope
to where the edge of my hair is and then
i move in a little bit and
just shave so yeah the edges are a bit
gross because i
don't want to cut off too much of the
long hair accidentally so i'd rather
cut off less than too much but yeah it's
surprisingly easy to do it myself
um you just have to like feel it and
then aim it
this is really nice and safe it doesn't
cut you or anything it just cuts hair
so you can just like do a lot of groping
without any sort of danger
so i hope this video was useful let me
know if you've used any of these
products before or if you have any
recommendations especially with a quick
hair dye
also with pink shampoo if you liked it
you can give it a thumbs up and
subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram at
lab laughing beauty science and check
out my blog if you like more of the
science behind beauty products see you
next time to nerd out more